accidents will happen but once in a
while their blessings in disguise take
TV show bloopers sometimes they make the
show funnier more convincing are just
more all-around interesting these
bloopers from popular TV shows were just
so perfect for the plot and characters
they had to stay in the final cut
Seinfeld the best Seinfeld episodes
featured the fabulous foursome
struggling with some kind of existential
nightmare perhaps the best example is
the 1991 episode the parking garage in
which the gang spends the entire story
wandering around a parking complex
unable to find their car until the very
end as scripted the episode was supposed
to finish with some small talk in the
group driving off their struggle finally
over but when actor Michael Richards put
the key in the ignition the car wouldn't
start and unplanned ending - cracked up
the cast and crew
[Music]
it's a more fitting and funnier way to
wrap up the story and it proved just too
good to cut Supernatural a commonly
uttered profane phrase doubled as a
catchphrase for paranormal investigator
Dean Winchester on Supernatural actor
Jason tackles uttered the line as an off
script addition while making the 2007
episode bad day at Black Rock solo rich
his boisterous hilariously frustrated
over-the-top delivery did a number on
co-star Jared Padalecki and the inspired
improvisation made it into the final
episode friends
Ross Geller was always a man with quirky
pursuits like playing experimental
keyboard music and owning a monkey for
example in the seventh season Friends
episode the one with Joey's new brain
Ross desperately wants to play the
bagpipes at Chandler and Monica's
upcoming wedding even though they aren't
interested and despite his complete
inability to actually play the
instrument during a sneak peak actress
Jennifer Aniston clearly can't handle it
and does everything in her power to not
break a real-life reaction too good to
leave on the cutting room floor How I
Met Your Mother
Wayne Brady's first big claim to fame
was as a gifted improvisational comic on
ABC's whose line is it anyway in Brady's
first episode is Barney's brother on the
sitcom How I Met Your Mother
actor Neil Patrick Harris made it his
mission to improvise a line that would
make Brady crack the one that worked a
reference to a song by Britney Spears
backup dancer turned husband Kevin
Federline
what what what cool what's up Brady had
to quickly duck away to keep him
cracking up on camera and awkward bit of
blocking but the end result was too
funny to cut the Brady Bunch
in his 1992 memoir growing up Brady
Barry Williams revealed he taped a scene
for the ultra innocent family sitcom
while completely stoned to be fair he
was a young dude in California in the
early 70s and he thought he had the day
off but then he got a call from the
producers who needed him on the set that
day after all
oops far out somehow nobody associated
with the Brady Bunch thought it was
weird that Williams tripped over his
bike pump awkwardly waved slurred his
words or looked the wrong way when
on screen little sister arrived on scene
all with a dopey grin on his face or
maybe a secret hero knew what was up and
decided to leave it in as a gift to
future generations Mystery Science
Theater 3000 this cult classic follows
the interstellar travails of a poor sap
and prison on a spaceship with a crew of
robots mocking the low-budget movies
they're forced to watch many of the
films are riddled with mistakes so it's
ironic that mst3k had its own
spectacular blooper make it into the
finished product inspired by a weapon in
a terrible movie called danger death ray
Tom servo made his own death ray and
fired it a crow that was all supposed to
happen the crow puppet however wasn't
supposed to catch fire he was just the
sort of anarchic silliness that made
Mystery Science Theater 3000 so special
so the take was used thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]